اعلنت طهران توصلها الى اتفاق مع واشنطن
يقضي بافراج متبادل عن سجناء وفك تجميد
مليارات الدولارات من عائدات النفط
الايراني اما واشنطن فاوضحت ان الاتفاق نص
على وضع جزء من اموال ايران المجمده في
حسابات الاستخدامها لاغراض انسانيه فقط
بينما اعربت الدوحه التي توسطت في الاتفاق
عن املها في ان يفدي الاتفاق الى توافقات
اشمل في الفتره المقبله
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى الاهميه التي
يكتسبها الاتفاق المبرم بين واشنطن وطهران
وما هي العوامل التي دفعت باتجاه التوصل
اليه في هذا التوقيت ما هي الانعكاسات
المحتمله لهذا الاتفاق على الاقليم وما
مدى امكانيه تطوره الى تفاهمات اوسع في
ملف القضايا العالقه بين طهران والغرب وما
دلاله ابرام الاتفاق بوساطه احدى دول
المنطقه وما الذي يبعثه ذلك من رسائل
باتجاه امكانيه تسويه خلافه المنطقه
بالطرق السلميه
[موسيقى]
في خضمي مخاوف اثارتها انباء التحشيد
والتحشيد المضاد بين واشنطن وطهران في
منطقه الخليج خلال الايام الماضيه خرجت
الخارجيه الايرانيه لتعلن عن توصل طهران و
واشنطن الى اتفاق ينص على افراج متبادل عن
سجناء ورفع التجميد عن مليارات الدولارات
من عائدات النفط الايراني التي احتجزتها
واشنطن بشكل غير قانوني وفق بيان الخارجيه
الايرانيه واضافت ان الافراج عن مليارات
الدولارات من اموال طهران المجمده بدا
بالفعل وان انفاقها سيكون وفق احتياجات
البلاد بحسب رؤيه المراجع المختصه
اما واشنطن فقد اوضحت على لسان جون كيربي
منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي ان ما يجري الحديث عنه
ووضع جزء من اموال ايران المجمده في
حسابات لاستخدامها لاغراض انسانيه فقط
ووصف كوربي في تصريح للجزيره ما انجز بانه
خطوه ايجابيه
لن اخذ في كثير من التفاصيل ولكن اعتقد
انه كان هناك بعض الالتباس فيما يتعلق
بفكره الاصول والاموال ما نتحدث عنه هنا
هو حسابات اقيمت في عهد الاداره السابقه
تسمح لبعض الدول باستيراد مواد غير خاضعه
للعقوبات من ايران ووضع الاموال المحصله
من ذلك في حساب يمكن ان يسحب منه
الايرانيون وقد فعلوا ذلك ابان الاداره
السابقه وفعلوه عده سنوات بعد ذلك ونحن
نتحدث هنا عن احتمال فتح حساب مماثل وجعله
مفتوحا اكثر امام الايرانيين لكن لن يكون
هناك اختلاف بشان كيف يمكن استخدام تلك
الاموال فهي ستستخدم فقط لاغراض انسانيه
من جانبه وصف الدكتور محمد بن عبد العزيز
الخليفي وزير الدوله بوزاره الخارجيه في
دوله قطر التي توسطت في الاتفاق بين
واشنطن وطهران وصف ما انجز بانه انعكاس
لثقه طرفيه في قطر كوسيط موثوق في مجال فض
النزاعات بالطرق السلميه
حرصت دوله قطر من اليوم الاول على ان
تبادر ايجابيا بوضع عدد من الضوابط
الواقعيه والمبادرات الايجابيه للطرفين
حتى تصل لهذا هذا النوع من التوافق ما بين
الطرفين وتحقيق الغايات المنشوده من ورا
هذا الاتفاق تجزر ايضا الاشاره هنا بان
سبق هذا الاتفاق زيارات مكثفه لعدد من
المسؤولين القطريين الى واشنطن وطهران
بهدف نقل هذه الرسائل وتقريب وجهات النظر
وتقديم هذه المبادره الايجابيه للوصول الى
هذا الاتفاق وما وصلنا اليه من اتفاق ولو
كان جزئي في هذه القضيه بالتحديد ما هو
الانعكاس على ثقه هذه الاطراف في دوله قطر
كوسيط محايد وشريك دولي موثوق في مجال فضل
المنازعات الدوليه بالطرق السلميه
[موسيقى]
اناقش الموضوع مع ضيفينا من واشنطن
الدكتور خليل العناني استاذه العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه ومن مدينه
ليدز في انجلترا الدكتور علم صالح استاذ
دراسات ايران وشرق الاوسط في الجامعه
الوطنيه الاستراليه مرحبا بكم يا دكتور
علم في ضوء التصعيد بين الطرفين قبل ايام
وارسال الولايات المتحده الامريكيه المزيد
من التعزيزات العسكريه والقطعه البحريه
الى منطقه الخليج لمواجهه ما قالت واشنطن
بانه زعزعه ايران لمسار الملاحه الدوليه
ما اهميه هذا الاتفاق
لا شك ان هذا هذا الاتفاق فريد جدا من
نوعه منذ 2018 لانها لم تكن اي اي اتفاق
بين الطهران واشنطن منذ ذلك ثانيا هي
اشاره ان
هي فوز للدبلوماسيه ضد
التصعيد التوترات وراينا ان
القطر
اخذت دور هام لاملاء هذا الامر بان حلول
المنطقه حلول مشاكل المنطقه لم تاتي من
خلال الحروب وتصعيد التوترات وارسال
المعسكرات
وايضا العقوبات بل تاتي من خلال الحوار
والدبلوماسيه وهذا امر جديد ايضا جدا كما
يبدو ان الطرفان طهران واشنطن
استنتج ان اكيد لم تكن هنالك اي مجال
لوصول الى حل كامل وشامل ولابد ان
يبتديون من من اي نوع من اتفاقيات
قصيره او او تكون ربما ضئيله ولكن في نفس
الوقت هامه جدا
لايجاد نوع من
الوثوق بين الطرفين وعندما نرى ان هذه
الاتفاقيه جاءت بعد تصعيد التوترات في
الاسابيع الماضيه لا شك انها ستؤدي الى
نوع من الحوار بين الاطراف او يستنتج ان
الحوار هو الحل الوحيد لحل مشاكل المنطقه
الدكتور خليل هل ينزع هذا الاتفاق فتيل
التوتر الذي ارتفع منسوبه في الايام
الماضيه في المنطقه
قد يكون ذلك بشكل مؤقت لكن ايضا نحن نتحدث
عن علاقات متوتره على مدار اكثر من 40
عاما لقطيع كامله بين الطرفين ليس هناك
عمل التوسط المباشر بينهما حتى في هذا
الملف كان هناك وسطات من اكثر من دوله
عمان وقطر اللاعب الدور مهم جدا للغايه
هذا الموضوع ايضا سويسرا وايضا هناك ملفات
اخرى معقده جدا من الصعب القول بان هناك
حاله انسجام او حاله من التوافق من
الطرفين هناك ملفات
ملتهبه مثلا ملف النووي الايراني ملف
متعلق بالوجود الايراني في سوريا وفي
العراق الملف المتعلق بالحفاظ على الهدوء
في منطقه الخليج العربي ملف المتعلق
باليمن وما الى ذلك وبالتالي هي خطوه اولى
جيده جدا في اطار ما يطلق عليه اجراءات
بناء الثقه بين الطرفين لكن ايضا لكن لا
يجب ان نبالغ فيها نحن اذا مرحله
الطرفين هناك شبه اتفاق حاليا على اطلاق
سراح خمسه
امريكيين من اصول ايرانيه مقابل الافراج
عن ما يقرب 6 مليار فيعتبر ما يطلق عليه
مكسب لكل طرف وكل الطرف لديه ايضا اهداف
داخليه فمن جهه هناك اهداف ايرانيه متعلقه
بمحاربه مواجهه الازمه الاقتصاديه التي
تعصف البلاد على اقل منذ اكثر من اربعه
اعوام نتكلم على اعلى معدلات تضخم في
ايران 40% على الاقل معدل البطاله اكثر من
20% معدل فقر ما يحصل من حوالي 20% ايضا
اكثر من ذلك وبالتالي هناك حاجه ماشيه جدا
لوجود اموال كي يتم حل حاله الامر
الاقتصادي في المقابل هناك حاجه ايضا
اداره بايدن من اجل ان تسوق هذا الموضوع
بافراج او باطلاق صلاح او مواطنه امريكيين
باعتباره مكسبا سياسيا خاصه نحن على ابواب
حمل انتخابيه ساخنه في ظل انتقالات كبيره
جدا من الجمهوريين لاداء اداره بايدن ويجب
ايضا جلال انه هذه هذا الاتفاق جاء نتيجه
لجهود مضنيه خلال عامين هو لم يحدث خلال
ايام او اسابيع او شهور بيتكلم على
مفاوضات عامين ماذا يعني هذا ما يعني انه
على الاقل بيض منذ ان جاء للسلطه قبل
عامين ونصف بدا بشكل اخر في اعاده رسم هذا
الملف والتواصل مع ايراني من خلال وسطاء
اقليميين لهم دور في هذا الاطار وبالتالي
يجب ان نفرق ما بين هذا الملف وملفات اخرى
قد تكون ربما نشات تحسن فيها لكنه ايضا
ليس لها ضمانات بوجود نوع من الفراغه
الكامله في الملفات الاخرى بين طرفين
الايراني والامريكي دكتور علم في سياق ما
قاله الدكتور خليل انت تفضلت بان هذا
الاتفاق هو دليل على ان الحوار ممكن ان
يفضي الى تفاهمات هل ممكن ان يغير هذا
الاتفاق من طبيعه المواجهه الحاده ما بين
ايران الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
صحيح ان المواجهه الايرانيه الامريكيه
معقده جدا وطبيعتها ترجع الى قبل ثمانيه
عقود فالقضيه ليست سهله ان تغير طبيعتها
باتفاقيه مثلك هذا ولكن اي اي امر معقد
جدا تحتاج الى خطوه ايجابيه اولا او او
خطوه
لتؤدي ربما الى خطوات ايجابيه اخرى
خاصه عندما نرى ان كلا الطرفين لديهما
اسباب او ادله كثيره لكي يصل الى الى هذه
النتائج الايجابيه مثلا الايران تحد وقود
اقتصاديه هائله جدا ولا تستطيع ان
تستمر بهذا الشكل لمده طويله ومن جهه اخرى
واشنطن لا تستطيع ان تطيق ايران النووي في
المنطقه ابدا خاصه في الظل الظروف الد
الراهنه اي اي الحرب الروسي الاوكراني
وقضيه الصين اللي هي تعتبر بالنسبه
للامريكيين هي الخطر الاول فلذلك
الامريكيون
يرون جيدا انه هزموا في افغانستان هزموا
في العراق هزموا في سوريا هزوا في اليمن
فالان والان هم منشغلين مع الصين ومع
الروس وان لا يستطيع ان يدخلوا في متاهات
هم في غنى عنها دكتور خليل انت اشرت الى
ان الاتفاق يعني بعد سنتين من التفاوض غير
المباشر ربما في اي ملف تفاوضى بين طهران
و واشنطن هناك مشكله انعدام الثقه الان
وقد تم الاتفاق على هذا الموضوع موضوع
تبادل السجناء والافراج عن اموال ايرانيه
وهو موضوع حساس بالمناسبه ليس فقط
الولايات المتحده وانما ايضا لدول في
المنطقه هل يمكن ان يكون بدايه لبناء ثقه
بين الطرفين للتفاهم على
ملفات شائكه اخرى
ربما ولا كان الامر يتوقف على مدى جديد
طرفين في هذا الاطار يعني مثلا ناخد
مجموعه ملفات او الملف ملف النووي
الايراني الامر لا يتعلق فقط بالطرفين
الامريكي والاسرائيلي عفوا لامريكا
واللايراني هناك الطرف الثالث مهم جدا في
معدته الطرف الاسرائيلي واسرائيل منذ على
اقل اعمالي ونصف
تحاول بكل الطرق افساد اي محاوله تقارب
بين الطرفين الامريكي والايراني وحاولت
اكثر من مره تعطيل مفاوضات الاتفاق النووي
سواء كان في فيينا سواء كان في الدوحه
الاخرى وبالتالي هناك مشكله حقيقيه فيما
يتعلق بهذه المساله الامر الثاني فضل يا
ترى ايضا انه سمعنا قبل حوالي سبعه اشهر
من الان ان هناك مناورات بحريه ومنورات
جويه عسكريه بين الطرفين الامريكي
والاسرائيلي تحاكم امكانيه التوجيه طلبات
عسكريه لمنفعات الايرانيه وهذا يعكس لحد
بعيد انه على الرغم من وجود خطاب امريكي
قد يكون بيسعى للتفاوض والحوار لكن في نفس
استعداد شكله اخر لامكانيه قيام باسرائيل
وبالتالي هناك موافقه امريكيه على اي قيام
بذلك بتوجيه طلبات عسكريه للقواعد او
للمواقع الايرانيه النوويه فهذا امر اخر
الامر الثالث متعلق بمادى وجود ثقه فيما
يتعلق او الحروب بالوكاله هناك تواجد
لايران فاكثر من ملف مثلا هناك تواجد لها
في العراق وتواجد في سوريا وراينا قبل
اربعه شهور يا استاذ جلال ان هناك شبه
يعني مواجهه عسكريه بين وكلاء ايران في
سوريا وكذلك قواعد العسكريه الموجوده في
سوريا وكانت هناك شبه اشتراكات عسكريه بين
الطرفين في ذلك الوقت ايضا هناك ملف الملف
اليمني وجود دور قوي فيما يتعلق بدعم
الحوثيين نعم نحن ازاء ما نسميه تبريد
لملفات في المنطقه تبريد للصراعات
لكن ايضا العلاقه الامريكيه الايرانيه
علاقه لا يجب ان لا يجب ان نجمع ملفات
فهناك فصل الملفات قد يكون هذا الاتفاق
بدايه مبشره وبدايه الضمانات ان يتحول لدى
الاتفاق الذي حدث بالامس الى تطبيع بين
الطرفين او الى الدفع في اتجاه ملفات اخرى
فيما يتعلق ملف النووي تحديدا ربما ربما
تلعب بالدوحه دور مهم في الاطار لماذا
لانه على الاقل هناك رغبه بين بالتوصل
لاتفاق اللي كنت اتفاق مؤقت وجزئي ما يطلق
عليه يعني او وقف للصراع بشكل او باخر
وهناك حديث وهناك ايضا مفاوضات سريعه حتى
هذه اللحظه وقرانا قبل حوالي اسبوعين في
الاخبار ان الدوحه تقوم بدور مهم جدا في
التواصل بين الطرفين بشكل غير مباشر من
خلال يعني وفود هنا وفود هناك من اجل
التوصل اتفاق ولو مؤقت يضمن عدم وصول
ايران الى معدل تخصيب 90% والذي يعتبر خط
احمر امريكي وقطعا طبعا اسرائيلي وبالتالي
ربما يبنى على ما حدث بالامس ان هناك
تواصل اتفقنا نووي ايراني بشكل مؤقت وليس
بشكل دائم كما يامل البعض في هذا السياق
التي تحدثت فيه دكتور
خليل
بورستيجونيل جورنال قالت بان ايران ابطات
وتيره التراكم اليورانيوم المخصب وخففت
مخزونها في خطوه قد تخفف التوتر مع واشنطن
وقالت بان الاوروبيين والامريكيين ابلغوا
ايران بانهم اكثر انفتاحا على محادثات
اوسع لاحقا دكتور علم هل هذا الاتفاق هو
جزء من اتفاقات اوسع ربما ستظهر في
المستقبل وتنفذ بشكل مجدول بتقديرك
لا شك عندما نرى الحجم الكبير من الاموال
للافرجت عنها من البنوك الكوريه والعراقيه
نرى انها لا يمكن ان تكون فقط لاعتقضيه
خمس سجناء الامريكيين المسجون في ايران
لابد ان تكون امور اهم من ذلك بكثير وهي
اتفاقيات ربما سريه حاليا وان
يحاول ان يصلوا اليها
بخطوات مستقبليه جدا اما بالنسبه لاسرائيل
لا ننسى ان اسرائيل هي اللي ادت الى ما
نحن فيه الان منذ عندما اتفق في في
اتفاقيه النوويه في 2015 ايران كانت تقسم
اليورانيوم اقل من اربعه بالمئه لمده ثلاث
سنوات الوكاله الدوليه للانتظاره
اثبتت النيران متعهده بالنسبه
لوعودها ولكن اسرائيل هي اللي شجعت ترامب
لخروج من الاتفاقيه وهذا ادى الى ما نحن
فيه الان ان الامريكيون هم الانس الان
سعيدون بان ايران تخسر ايرانهم الى نسبه
60% اي هي تقريبا
قريبه جدا الى الى السلاح النووي اذا
ارادوا ان يصلوا اليك فلذلك الاسرائيل لا
يجب ان لم تكن احد
الاسباب او او اللاعبين في هذه الاتفاقيه
لان هي اساسا اسرائيل او التلابيب تعيش
سياساتها سياسه ضد ايران
ودرا هذا الشيخ خاصه في في
الدوله الحاليه او دوله نتنياهو اليمينيه
المفرطه فلذلك
واشنطن تعرف ان اسرائيل منافع تختلف جدا
عن المنافع اللي لمنطقه تحتاجها حاليا
دكتور خليل التوتر بين واشنطن وايران
ساحته الاساسيه منطقه الخليج والشرق
الاوسط لياتي هذا الاتفاق بوساطه من احدى
دول المنطقه الى ماذا يؤشر هذا
هذا يؤشر انه نحن ازاء فرصه تاريخيه الان
ان هناك دول لديها قدر من الثقه بين
الطرفين مثلا مثل الدوحه او عمان ان هناك
امكانيه اذا كانت هناك نوايا طيبه ونوايا
خالصه ونوايا تسعى باتجاه خفض التوتر في
المنطقه هناك امكانيه للبناء على ما حدث
بالامس من اجل التوصل اتفاقات اخرى في
قضايا اخرى قد تمهد الى سحب فتاهيه التوتر
بين الطرفين راينا كما قلت مقدمه هذه
الحلقه انه على مدار اخر اخر اربع خمس
اسابيع هناك حاله تحشيد وتحشيد مضاد هناك
لاول مره سعي امريكي لوضع جنود المشاه
البحريه الامريكيه على اسطح ناقلات نفط
ونقلات تجاره في منطقه الخليج العربي هرمز
في المقابل هناك مناورات عسكريه لحرس
الثوري الايراني منورات بحريه يصل ماذا
بعض الصواريخ لحوالي 600 كيلو متر على
الاقل هذا كان نوع من التصعيد من الطرفين
وان لو قد لا قدر نوع من الاشتباك قد ربما
دخول في مواجهه عسكريه اقليميه لا تدخل
اعتذر على في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي وجود
دول مثل قطر او عمان لديهم علاق بين
الطرفين وتسعى بكل جهد بشكل باخر نادي
التواصل الاتفاق او لصيغه قد تؤدي خطوات
يعتبر امر جيد للغايه السؤال والتحدي هنا
هل سيسمح لهم من خلال اطراف الخارجيه هناك
عده امور لامر غير متعلقه بمقال الدكتور
علام متعلق باسرائيل ليس لديها مصلحه
الاطلاق في وجود اي نوع من الهدوء في
علاقات الامريكيه الايرانيه لماذا يعتبر
تحول في موازين الاوسط الامر الاخر متعلق
ايضا بعلاقه ايران
باهم قسمين لامريكا حاليا هم الصين وروسيا
ايران تعتبر من اهم الداعمين العسكريين
لروسيا في الحرب على اوكرانيا اكبر عدد من
المسيرات التي استخدمها روسيا في الحرب
على اوكرانيا خاصه في كييف وهو المتعلق
الايران هناك دعم عسكري وشبه تحالف
استراتيجيه بنيران وبين موسكو وبالتالي
هذا يعتبر تحدي كبير لامريكا وحرب الوكاله
من خلال الحرب في اوكرانيا الامر متعلق
بعلاقات الصينيه الايرانيه علاقات متقدمه
للغايه خاصه في مجال الطاقه ومجال النفط
وبالتالي هل ستقوم ايران بتخفيض العلاقه
مع موسكو وبكين من اجل ان تكون لك على
علاقه طيبه مع امريكا
التالي رغم وجود النوايا طيبه رغم وجود
وسطات فموجود دول علاقات طيبه يتوقف الامر
على على مدى سماح الاطراف الدوليه بذلك
ومدى وجود اصرار لدى طهران واشنطن على
مدير قدما فيما يتعلق
علاقات تبدو طبيعيه في المستقبل بعيد على
الاقل ايضا في سياق الحديث عن عن المنطقه
الدكتور علم من الرسائل التي يرسلها هذا
الاتفاق لمحور في المنطقه يرى في ايران
بانها شر مطلق وبانها تهدد الامن
والاستقرار لعديد من دوله
الخطر الوحيد العسكري ضد ايران كانت حضور
امريكا في المنطقه منذ
فلذلك نرى منذ تخفيض الدور وحضور الامريكي
في المنطقه
قبل ربما ثلاث سنوات او اربع سنوات
ليومنا هذا
الامور
او راينا تخفيض او تخفيض التوترات
وراينا هدوء نسبيا في المنطقه وايران ايضا
تصرفاتها اصبحت اكثر
عقلانيه فلذلك ادت الى تحسين العلاقات مع
بعض الدول دول في المنطقه
وايضا عندما نرى صحيح ان ايران تقربت الى
الروس والصين ولكن هذه ايضا كانت نتيجه
ضغوطات امريكيه اقتصاديه وايضا تهديداتها
والخروج ترامب من الاتفاقيه منذ 2018 بعد
الاتفاقيه ايران اتوقعت عقود بالمئات
المليارات الدولار مع شركات الامريكان
الغربيه ولكن بعد خروج ترامب ايضا ايران
لم تكن لديها اي حل الا الى الا اذا تقربت
الى الروس والصين فلذلك نرى ان السياسات
امريكا ضد ايران منذ 2018 فشلت بالنسبه
للنشاطات ايران النوويه نشاطات ايران
الصاروخيه وايضا السياساتها في المنطقه
وسياسات الدوليه مع الصين وروسيا اسمع
رايك دكتور خليل انعكاسات المحتمله لهذا
الاتفاق على محورين اذا صح القول في في
المنطقه
يعني بلا شك اي اي تخفيض التوتر اي تواصل
اتفاق بين اطراف المتصارعه في المنطقه
العربيه يعتبر خطوه ايجابيه راينا على
سبيل المثال قبل حوالي اربعه اشهر من الان
او خمسه شهور في 10 مارس الماضي لاول مره
اختراق تاريخي فيما يتعلق علاقات بين
السعوديه بين ايران هذا يعتبر تحول نوعي
في المنطقه العربيه الامر الاخر اين ايضا
ما يطلق على او تقارب بين دول كان بينها
نوع من القطيعه مثل مصر وتركيا ودول اخرى
وبالتالي هناك حاله اعاده موضوع في
المنطقه العربيه تقوم بها الدول تؤدي بشكل
اخر الى خفض التصعيد لكن ايضا هناك اطراف
اخرى جلال متعلقه او اطراف اخرى تسعى بكل
جهد وبكل الطرق من اجل التوطير العلاقات
في المنطقه العربيه وراينا اسرائيل تحديدا
الاطار خاصه بوجود حكومه يمنيه متطرفه
تسعى لعدم وجود نعمه الثقافه المنطقه
العربيه خاصه التحديدا وبالتالي اذا كان
هناك اصرار من الطرفين الامريكي والايراني
على المضي قدما وعدم الالتفات لكل هذه
المحاولات التخريبيه قد نجد ان هناك
بالفعل مرحله جديده في المنطقه العربيه خف
التوتر وجود علاقات قد تبدو طبيعيه كل هذه
الاطراف وبالتالي عدم وجود صراعات الامر
يتوقف على مدى الجلديه مدى حسن النوايا
مدى الاسفار على مدير قدما فيما يتعلق
بهذه المنطقه المتحده من العالم السؤال
الاخير ربما دكتور علم رغم الايجابيه التي
ظهرت فيها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لان
بلانكن اصر وشدد امام الصحفيين بالقول
بانهم مستمرون في فرض العقوبات على ايران
وعلى مواجهه ما يسمونه زعزعه ايران
للاستقرار في المنطقه هذا الى ماذا يؤشر
بتقديرك
الولايات المتحده تتواصل بضغوطاتها على
ايران لان مساله ايران ليست فقط مساله
النوويه ام ام السجناء
او التقنيه للصاروخيه او او المسيرات فهي
قضيه
المنطقه ايران دوله تستطيع ان تتحدى
القدرات الامريكيه في المنطقه فلذلك هذا
شيء لا شك ان واشنطن لا تطيقها فلذلك هذا
الامر سيتواصل والامر يكون طويل
وصعب جدا وحتكون هنالك ايجابيات وسلبيات
كثيره
فلذلك هنا دور بلدان
مثل قطر وعمال حتكون هام جدا لكي
يتواصلوا ويصلوا الى حوار نسبي لحل مشاكل
المنطقه معك دكتور خليل ايضا في في نفس
السؤال ما الذي يعني هذا التصريح من في
هذا الوقت الايجابي
تصريح مهم للغايه يعكس ان هناك امكانيه
لتجاوز خلافات موجوده بين الطرفين
الامريكي والايراني لكن ايضا مهمه جدا في
هذه الحلقه متعلقه بالاطراف الداخليه في
كل دوله يعني هل هناك مثلا قبول جمهور
لهذا الاتفاق اعتقد سيكون هناك نقد شديد
جدا لاداره بايدن هذا الامر حدث ايضا
عندما قام اوباما قبل حوالي 5 تعامل الان
في 2016 باعطاء ايران منكم من حوالي 11
مليار دولار منها على الاقل 400 مليون
دولار كاش هذا الامر كان يعتبر يعني امر
مختلف ودفع بضغوط شديده جدا على اوباما
ونقد له من الجمهوريين هل سنشهد الامر
ايضا خاصه نحن موسم انتخابي ساخن كما قلت
قبل قليل في امريكا الامر الاخر ايضا فيما
يتعلق بامكانيه ان يتم يعني ترويج او بيعه
للمحافظين داخل ايران هل ستقبل الامر ام
لو بالتالي نحن ازاء مرحله يجب ان ننتظر
حتى نرى اهم تدفق على ملتقى فيما ياتي او
في قادم الايام شكرا لكم الدكتور خليل
عناني في واشنطن والدكتور علم صالح في
ليدس بنجل ترا
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه الى
اللقاء بامان الله والعيد
[موسيقى]